what up people some time ago I made a
video about some unappreciated anime
that people overlooked in their heyday
well what do you know with the amount of
anime coming out every season before
this one at least you can't avoid the
sad fact that eventually something is
going to get overshadowed by four or
five hard hitters in a season
therefore we'll go once again back to
the topic of underrated anime and for
this video I'll be taking you through a
tour of ten more anime that I think
deserve more love than they got
coming from the well-renowned pa works
no for their slice of life dramas is a
vampire series really something's wrong
there isn't it this doesn't look like a
coming-of-age story or a drama set in
rural Japan PA works does manage to pull
out a surprise or two now and again and
I personally think that seriously Yaga
is one of them it tells the story of
1930s Japan where vampires have appeared
facing against them are the jaegers the
group of vampire hunters that includes
our protagonist you leak however the
fight between the jaegers and the
vampires is not what it seems
beneath the surface the two factions are
actually fighting over the Ark of Sirius
a powerful artifact that could change
the fate of the world I wouldn't say
this serious the jaegers something
really high up the PA works totem pole
given the studio's resume and how it
emitted Lee saturated the vampire genre
has become over the years but
nonetheless I still think that this show
deserves a little bit more love it has
good action a nice premise and some
really top class visuals that capture
the setting so well I didn't expect PA
works to come up with an action thriller
in the first place and I'm pleasantly
surprised at how it turned out given my
expectations man you are mu upon your
hope
now I like to call the 2000s all the way
to the early 2010's as the era of the
battle shown in as far as mainstream
anime goes super-powered teens galore
and they come in all sorts of flavours
back in that time it's kind of like a
Sakai in the modern era and it's kind of
hard to stand out actually and such is
the unfortunate fate of code breaker
for me one of the last notable ones
riding on the ever fading momentum of
the big three as battle shown and began
the transition into the new stars is
code breaker I mean it's not that
popular and that's why it ended up on
this list in the first place I mean it's
not that bad a show I think that code
breaker does have the unique gimmick of
being a battle show name that explores
the idea of good and evil instead of
focusing on friendship or growing up
just watching is good and what is evil
what is justice those are questions that
the series set out to answer with its
two main characters who have an
interesting dynamic of their own it may
be a far cry from being anime of the
year in 2012 but I think the code
breaker is overall actually a decent
watch if you are for some darker battle
Shonen and have a bit of time to spare
it's certainly deserved a bit more
popularity than it did get back then
now here's another anime that didn't air
too far back in ehe key tells the story
of itchy root an almost retired family
man going through typical old man
problems
his body's giving out he has cancer and
his family apparently hates him so he
naturally finds solace in his dog like
any near retiree would however in one
emotional trip with his dog he gets
caught in an explosion and lo and behold
he gets reborn as a cyborg being the
good-natured man that he is he decides
to use his newfound powers to help other
people unfortunately he's not alone in
being affected by the explosion the
teenage shishi gommi also gains powers
but he's not using them for good
thus begins the battle between
generations and ideals for the fate of
Japan I'd say that Moffat did one
amazing job at adapting this manga the
visuals look amazing and add to that
spectacle a super-powered cyborg grandpa
fighting to save Japan I was hooked from
the get-go in this story that goes
beyond the standard good versus evil
fair and was quite surprised that the
series wasn't as popular as I expected
it to be I guess it just had to do with
how while the premise sounds katana got
thirty at number seven seeing the
gallery at the end of the title and the
name of the author I won't blame you if
you mistake katana gallery as another
entry in the storied monogatari
franchise I thought so when I was about
to get into the show as well now while
the two series have similarities being
from the same writer and all I think
that katana gar 3 stands out as its own
thing altogether this is mostly helped
by the art style which is unlike most of
the things we see in modern anime the
characters stand out flamboyantly
against the signature backgrounds at the
show employees
it seems that Nishio Essen also has an
affinity for good dialogue in monogatari
and it shows as early as this series one
I know a lot of you would have preferred
more action in a story about you know
sorts I guess it all worked out in the
end
katana gar 3 really stands out for how
nice it does seem at times while by no
means an unpopular series I do think
that this is one of those animes that
deserves just a little bit more love
it's not a long series so it shouldn't
be a time thing that would deter a lot
of Watchers plus it's just a testament
to the greatness of the author known as
Nishio Eason
sitka Hudson I mentioned that mm to the
early 2010's can be considered a heyday
for shown in series and that it's so
easy to get lost in the shuffle another
one of those that got lost in the
shuffle is Beelzebub's combining action
and a lot of comedy it tells the story
of Tatsumi ogre the king of the toughest
school of delinquents in town naturally
he gets picked to be the caretaker of
the son of the Demon Lord baby Beel of
course things don't go easy for someone
who just found the future Lord of the
underworld joining the fray is the
underworld super-competent made and the
peerless
ogre might have found his match he may
be the king of the delinquents the how
early fair in dealing with the prospect
of fatherhood non-stop laughs awaiting
this comedy anime the plot does turn
serious a couple of times but make no
mistake this is purely shown in comedy
not quite in the veins of Gintama but
you get the point don't you if you're up
for some crazy fun it's time to put this
anime on your to watch list now before
we move on some of you guys might have a
very important question in your minds
you might be saying to yourself hey
these shows are awesome and all but I
can't watch them legally crunchyroll and
Netflix in my region just don't have
these shows well then let me introduce
you to the sponsors of this video
Express vpm all you need to do is open
the app choose a country and connect to
your server of choice say goodbye to all
those blocked websites and region locks
in a simple click it has by far the
smoothest and fastest speeds in any VPN
service I've used before it sounds
awesome right here let me help you out
by giving you three months free and all
you have to do is click the link below
or just go to expressvpn comm slash vini
tube so what are you waiting for bypass
all those pesky region locks and even
browse sites not available in your
region with the ever trusty expressvpn
now right let's get back to the show
[Music]
not to be confused with psy games
money-making machine grand blues a
comedy series starring EOD get the hata
and his new life after moving into the
coastal town of a zoo living in Grande
blue his uncle's diving shop he finds
out the unfortunate fact that the shop
is in fact being used as a base of
operations by the local diving Club
which is composed of partying drunkards
making matters worse is his female
cousin catching him in an embarrassing
party situation welcome to the crazy
life in a zoo a Horry better strapped
down and brace yourself in my opinion
granblue differentiates itself from most
of its peers in the genre by featuring
college students colleges generally the
time of discovery where people go hard
either in partying studying or other
ways I think that ground blow did a good
job presenting the fact of college being
both the carefree time and a time where
people venture out and start learning
the realities of life with this
shenanigans it's not too hard to spend
your time laughing yourself dry while
watching this series I did record some
people talking about Grande blue when it
aired some two years ago but if you're
in the same season as an attack on Titan
season and an overlord season it kind of
gets hard to stand out shining bright at
number four is a land of the lustrous
we've seen ships airplanes and whatnot
get turned into girls
how about gyms introducing you to the
brilliant 27 series land of the lustrous
man of the lustrous is set in a world
inhabited by gems the gems must fight
for survival against Lunarians beings
who attack them in order to turn them
into decorations force our protagonist
aims to aid in the battle against the
Lunarians
however being the fragile gem that she
is she gets assigned to compile the
world's history instead a five-dollar
task than what she dreamt of this series
managed to fly under the radar despite
the interesting premise perhaps it was
maybe a lack of hype perhaps it was
because 2017 had a lot of good anime or
maybe because it was a CGI animated CGI
anime but I really truly feel this anime
showed us that CGI anime can actually
look really amazing if it's done right
if you've seen be stars which was made
by the same studio by the way you know
exactly what I'm talking about
whatever the reason land of the lustrous
deserves a lot more love for being an
enjoyable show about chain
and self-discovery how about something
eSports related for our third place
entry let me introduce to you King's
avatar it's easy to see why Kings avatar
can be considered an underappreciated
show first of all by the time it came
out gaming shows have become commonplace
it feels it's kind of harder to stand
out now as an up-and-comer in the genre
the second thing is it's a Chinese anime
and I can't help but think that is
partially why it didn't get that much
traction with the more casual side of
the fanbase now that's a shame as well
because I think that King's avatar is an
anime that separates itself from the lot
by being character focused we're all too
used to the million people getting
trapped in video game shows or them
playing casual adventures with friends
such as the case of Neto Guinot llame or
Bo Furi which I consider premise centric
in Kings Abbott are the characters
specifically our protagonist Yu Shu are
the centerpiece and they undergo similar
changes as the characters we've grown to
love but are slightly different beats
let me make it clear that this is not
completely an eSports anime however it
does tell a good story about our main
character a powerful glory player forced
into retirement through politics to
genuinely growing and loving the game
once more if you have the time and I run
for some gaming anime you should
definitely give this one a shot next up
is one of the great thrillers at the
midpoint of the decade Arjun years past
the titular Arjun or Demi humans
appeared carrying the ability to suffer
fatal injuries and not die they
considered a huge boon for research all
over the world now what happens when
those monsters strike back that's the
basic premise of this thriller starring
Kane the guy who finds his world turned
upside down the moment he awakens as an
Arjun forget friendships when your
bounty is high there are no such thing
as friends except for his delinquent
friend on the Randi Kaye looks to find
the Society of Arjun however the
survivors that form this group don't
take too kindly to humans now when I
first read the premise I somehow got
reminded of Tokyo ghoul or parasite
all-in-all Arjun goes in a pretty
different direction but it's nonetheless
a good watching experience it does raise
some questions about what constitutes a
human and does feature one of the better
villains off the top of my head the CG
might take a while to get used to but
don't let that stop you from watching
this interesting series
so tonight as classic literature and
anime is a combination that has
delivered to use a mixed bag grabbing
the top spot on our list is God good
sOooo given his legacy I'm not surprised
that The Count of Monte Cristo got the
anime treatment well I didn't expect to
see was how underrated it is for
something that's so good must be the age
since this is a 2004 series it's either
that or something along the lines of
classic literature anime just not being
popular enough either way God good sOooo
is the reimagining of The Count of Monte
Cristo now a lot of you who've taken
your literature class probably know of
Edmond Dantes quest for revenge but in
gun good soooo his tale gets remade to
include some sci-fi elements it's a
creative adaptation through and through
yet the story still sticks and carries
itself really nicely with its
thought-provoking narrative and great
characters that's not even getting to
the unique and charming art style that
the series employs the opinion on the
art is divided but I think it helps add
to the classic Flair that the series is
going for gone so came away with a
winner of a mid 2000 series and that
just about wraps it up for this list 10
more underappreciated anime for you with
so many more anime on my mind who knows
maybe we can get a third volume of this
list if this video gets 15,000 likes
then I'll definitely consider making one
don't forget to check out our sponsors
of this video express vpm bypass all
those pesky region locks and even browse
sites not available in your region with
the ever trusty expressvpn now I'll see
you next time on vinnie tube
[Music]
you